et que la majorité des gens
soutiennent toujours la Russie,
mais je crois aussi qu'une majorité de
gens n'ont pas un accès adéquat à
des informations objectives
[Musique]
nous devons faire quelque chose parce que, comme
en Chine, il n'y a pas de médias officiels
ou de représentants des médias officiels ukrainiens
et  c'est pourquoi l'ukraine s'est formé après
peut-être
quatre
quatre cinq jours après avoir
commencé à traduire son site Web en
chinois parce que comprendre que nous
perdons cette bataille médiatique
attendez une seconde le site Web va juste
[Musique] d'accord,
nous nous battons pour la liberté, nous nous
battons pour eux
les nouvelles pour lesquelles nous nous battons pour la
vérité
parce que c'est ce qui est important
nous voulons
que les Ukrainiens soient ici
vous